un soir menant garé sa voiture pour
assister à un spectacle elle ne remarque
pas un peu plus loin des panneaux
temporaires qui interdisent le
stationnement justement à cause de
l'événement auquel elle assiste en
revenant une voiture on l'a remarqué en
plus de lui donner un constat on doit
aller chercher sa voiture en taxi et
payer les frais de remorquage
elle conteste sa contravention en cour
municipale
elle affirme que les panneaux
temporaires n'étaient pas visibles elle
est acquittée
mona en conclut que la ville doit lui
rembourser et le remorquage et le taxi
la ville de son côté répond que son
agent n'a pas commis de faute qui
entraîne sa responsabilité qui a raison
nous avons consulté deux juristes ils
s'entendent pour dire que la réponse de
la ville est tout à fait juste simona
veut obtenir un remboursement elle devra
aller devant un tribunal il prouver que
la ville a commis un geste déraisonnable
ou encore qu'elle a fait preuve de
grande négligence de crème ou de
l'histoire un kit main ne rime pas
toujours avec remboursement